collège visitation la berlière cours de
sciences sociales aujourd'hui normes
valeurs et intérêts avant de commencer
le coeur de ces vidéos j'aimerais faire
avec vous un petit rappel la société
nous transmet par un mécanisme qui est
appelé la socialisation différents
comportements que nous vous devons
adopter mais aussi des règles de
conduite à suivre des grands principes
moraux ainsi que des idées qu'on appelle
représentation l'ensemble de ces
éléments nous sont transmis par des
agents de socialisation qui ne sont
autres que la famille que nos amis les
groupes de pairs l'école ou de grande
institution comme l'église où les médias
aujourd'hui nous allons nous intéresser
à un des éléments qui nous est transmis
par la socialisation les normes et des
concepts qui sont directement liés ceux
de valeurs d'intérêt
enfin nous verrons que ces différents
éléments sont autant de filtres qui vont
influencer nos jugements de la réalité
qui nous entoure
les normes sont des règles de conduite
explicites ou implicites qui oriente le
comportement des individus conformément
aux valeurs de la société
vous avez devant vous deux cas de normes
qui sont respectées ou non dans le cas
de la première photo où j'ai deux
personnes qui sont assises dans un
fauteuil
la première personne qui est à gauche en
chemise bleue respectent les normes de
la société
c'est ce qui est attendu d'une femme
dans une situation comme celle là
la deuxième personne évidemment enfreint
les normes et celles qui sont
particulièrement lié au groupe social
auquel elle appartient catégorie sociale
à laquelle elle appartient
c'est à dire les personnes de sexe
féminin en ce qui concerne la seconde
photo que certains d'entre vous
connaissent bien évidemment on a là
aussi la rupture d'une norme n'est pas
attendue dans nos sociétés que les
personnes âgées soient tatoué et encore
moins d'une façon importante comme celle
ci
cette photo va donc jeu
choquée tout comme les piercings ou les
anneaux qui sont aux oreilles de cette
personne
les valeurs sont quant à elles des
grands principes moraux des idéaux
auxquels les membres d'une société ader
et qui se manifeste concrètement dans la
vie de tous les jours par des manières
de penser des manières de sentir et des
manières d'agir c'est à dire des
comportements en un certain sens les
valeurs sont les grands principes sur
lesquels vont se fonder les normes les
normes ne sont que la traduction de ces
valeurs en termes concrets pour les
individus l'exemple qui est repris ici
et provient d'un de nos élèves montrent
les valeurs qui sont actives par rapport
à certaines situations et ici celle
d'une cliente d'un célèbre fast food qui
se dit écoeuré par l'attitude d'un
personnel du personnel de ce fast food
par rapport à un sans abri dit mais dans
quel monde vit-on sous-entendus mais
voilà quel est ce monde qui ne
respectent plus les valeurs auxquelles -
je souscris et que l'on m'a sans doute
appris enfin notre action peut bien sûr
être le fruit des normes en vigueur dans
la société
peut-être évidemment une fondée sur de
grandes valeurs
mais peut surtout prendre appui sur nos
propres intérêts les intérêts sont en
fait le fruit d'un calcul rationnel donc
c'est à dire vraiment d'une réflexion de
quelque chose de réfléchi des individus
qui vont prendre un coup en compte d'un
côté les coûts que
engendrer certaines actions et les
bénéfices qui seront permis par ces
mêmes actions est évidemment si pour
l'individu les bénéfices sont supérieurs
aux coûts il agira plus facilement à ce
stade de l'exposé il est important de
dire que norme valeurs et intérêts vont
s'articuler pour offrir aux individus un
cadre le père leur permettant d'agir ce
cadre évidemment ne va pas être le même
d'une société à l'autre une société va
privilégier certaines valeurs et il y
aura d'homme donc certainement qui
seront en vigueur tandis que d'autres
vont peut-être être moins moix et
l'heure en tout cas la socialisation sur
les valeurs et c'est plutôt l'intérêt
qui va émerger comme élément vraiment
pertinent pour l'action des individus
donc l'articulation entre normes valeurs
et intérêts dépend véritablement de
l'espace c'est à dire de la société dans
laquelle on se trouve
mais aussi vont évoluer dans le temps
nos sociétés n'avaient pas les mêmes
valeurs et n'avaient pas les mêmes
normes il ya cent ans que maintenant ce
qui est important finalement de dire
pour conclure c'est que ces normes ses
intérêts et ses valeurs sont des filtres
qui vont s'interposer qui vont se mettre
entre nous même entre nos sens et la
société c'est à dire le réel
nous allons voir les choses d'une
manière différente en fonction des
normes auxquelles nous avons été sans
socialiser seront différentes en
fonction des valeurs auxquelles nous
croyons nous nous rattachons et en même
temps ce seront clairement différenciés
selon nos intérêts il convient également
de dire que ces normes ses valeurs et
ses intérêts seront différentes d'une
société à l'autre mais aussi d'un groupe
social à l'autre des groupes socio
économiquement défavorisées n'auront pas
les mêmes normes les mêmes valeurs que
des groupes
favoriser cette vidéo maintenant
terminer je vous propose de passer à
l'application alors nous allons nous
baser sur un film les visiteurs qui fait
l'objet d'une vidéo différentes donc les
consignes de la préparation
vous en êtes où sont expliquées dans
cette vidéo vous êtes un bon travail et
à très bientôt